[Norvig] Now, I said that with the correct shuffle algorithm,
the Algorithm P, every permutation of the deck has an equal probability.
The next question is, for the teacher's algorithm
does every permutation have an equal chance? What do you think?
Yes, they're all the same, it just takes longer to get them;
no, some of them will be different, have a different probability;
or no, some will have a 0 probability,
that there will be some permutations that it's impossible for the teacher's shuffle to generate.
Tell me which you think.
This is a hard question. It takes some analysis to be able to figure it out.
You may be able to tell just by looking at the algorithm,
or you may want to write some code to analyze what the situation is.